(upbeat music)
- We started by looking WMD's,
which at the time I assumed
was a way to classify
yourself on a dating site.
(laughter)
Right.
I remember thinking
why are we searching
for white middle
aged dads in Iraq?
(laughter)
It doesn't make sense.
We've got enough
of them here right?
- He is a person of color
and he's more sensitive to
issues of bigotry and
I think he's gonnna be,
he doesn't want to equate Islam
with extremist violent people.
- Is it harder because he's
a secret muslim from Kenya,
does that make it harder?
(laughter)
I'll give you guys
the opportunity
to ask me any one
of these, which one?
- Islamophobia sexism.
I'd say...
Let's get rid of the
(laughs) that one is hard.
Oh my god.
(booing)
No, hold on.
No, you guys, you know
we'll be right back.
I'll tell you in act four.
Hey America, Larry Wilmore here.
If you like the Nightly
Show on Comedy Central
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me, I
do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.